check out Dwayne the rock Johnson's epic  dance moves as a giant Pokemon character  the Pikachu costume would inspire that  my baby girl was at a pumpkin patch  there was a Pikachu a guy in a Pietra  costume and she went crazy we thought  you know what daddy's gonna wear Pikachu  caucus with daddy's dude it's not only  Halloween it's about once a week  Dwayne's doing double duty as another  animated character he's Maui and  Disney's new movie Moana representing  his Samoan heritage it's already being  called the next rose and get this you've  actually sings in breathe you're welcome  as it said in what it will mean how many  kids will grow up watching you I have a  15 year old daughter who represents  Moana by the way can I have an 11 month  old baby girl who represents baby Moana  in many ways so it's very special  there's a lot there's yeah I'm gonna  need a shrink  finally about six months